Mike looks like louis ck's genitals
because he's about to get beat in front
of an audience
[Applause]
[Music]
what a fun battle this is between two
roasts Reuters Mian who's ever helping
Tony tonight I just can't wait to see
what fat ugly nerds you hired to call me
a fat ugly nerd if you want to see
something Tony's running all by himself
you could just go to his Wikipedia page
[Music]
everybody knows Mike's a great writer
that's how he got the Emmy nom nom nom
nom nom Mike wrote on the last season of
Schumer's show and the last season of
crashing he's ended more shows than
Harvey Weinstein's boner yeah I am fed I
am literally twice the comic you are
[Applause]
Tony hosts a podcast where he mentors
young comedians giving them advice like
how to get a Netflix special and how to
still be cocky after Netflix takes that
special down
hey man Wow I'm sorry they only have
room for one depressing lesbian at a
time fancy way of saying Mike's never
made a special but his parents made 135
years ago
[Applause]
Tony married an Australian woman after
one month in Las Vegas and you know what
they say what happens in Vegas leaves
you the second she gets her green card
hey Tony let me ask you when she
divorces you is she gonna flush every
memory away of you clockwise instead of
counterclockwise it's true we are we are
both married my beautiful wife is right
up there Mike's wife couldn't uh yes
Mike Mike's wife couldn't be here
tonight because clearly Mike never makes
her come
[Applause]
last week they asked me to battle Tony
Hinchcliffe and ever since then I've
done nothing but think about Tony
Hinchcliffe and now I know what it's
like to be Tony Hinchcliffe it's a damn
good feeling Mike it's a damn good
feeling last Joe this has been a lot of
fun battling homeless Simpson mike is a
huge professional wrestling fan even
before the show tonight I saw him throw
himself through the craft service table
[Applause]
nice one you bobblehead of a trump son
Kevin Tony
[Music]
[Applause]
Tony is the Kevin Spacey of comedy he's
creepy closeted and Netflix has cut all
ties with him
[Applause]